going to do a fantastic job and I
appreciate you there had been growing
divisions between John Bolton and his
boss but the end was brutal even by the
standards of this White House Donald
Trump tweeting I informed John Bolton
last night that his services are no
longer needed at the White House I
disagreed strongly with many of his
suggestions as did others in the
administration therefore I asked for his
resignation which was given to me this
morning
Bolton tweeted not the usual thanks for
being able to serve but an insistence
he'd quit
rather than been fired at a news
briefing at the White House which Bolton
was initially listed to attend even
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo defended
the president's decision the president's
entitled to the staff that he wants at
any moment this is a staff person who
works directly for the president United
States and he should have people he
trusts and values there were many times
ambassador Bolton I disagree that's to
be sure but that's true for lots of lots
of people who with whom I interact John
Bolton was Donald Trump's third national
security adviser of the longest serving
so far but with his stated positions of
using military force in Iran in North
Korea he was an odd fit for a president
who's isolationist America first policy
wanted to reduce the US military
footprint Bolton was against talking to
North Korea against killing US troops
out of Syria and against the president's
latest idea of inviting Afghanistan's
Taliban to peace talks at Camp David
that seems to have been the breaking
point we have seen from this and from
every other firing that what he really
wants are people that echo what he
already wants to do and with Bolton's
opposition gone there could be obvious
changes for example there's a better
chance the president will meet with his
Iranian counterpart presence very very
clear he's prepared to meet with no
preconditions before he became president
Donald Trump considered John Bolton for
the role of Secretary of State but
ultimately decided against it because he
felt he didn't look the part mainly
because of his mustache now after 18
months as the national security adviser
John Bolton once again finds that his
face doesn't fit Allen Fisher al Jazeera
at the White House